les bonnes vieilles habitudes ne se
perdent pas côté garage les amateurs ont
profité de l'opération portes ouvertes
du grand prix du canada pour s'approcher
des pilotes et des équipes au travail
les mécaniciens à l'heure où l'on
dansait on peut être je tout le monde on
peut les voir vraiment de paix avec ce
sacre est vraiment la différence dont le
garage renault on apprécie dans le tout
nouveau bâtiment central l'espace
supplémentaire pour travailler
côté paddock
lewis hamilton a comme tous ses
collègues étaient impressionnés par ce
changement de décor ce matin on va pas
on voit pas ça partout
c'est sûr le grand prix du canada andré
les plus tard avec un nouveau set up
show des tubes et les nouvelles
installations ont passé le test de la
première impression reste à savoir
maintenant si les équipes s'y sentiront
à l'aise dans le déroulement de leur
week-end de travail
les voitures et les pilotes entrent en
piste vendredi matin 10h heure locale
pour la première séance d'essai libre
avec notamment le pilote montréalais de
naissance nichols latifi chez williams
et bien sûr lindstrom ch racing pointe
philippe rey pour radio-canada au
circuit gilles villeneuve